let's go to Bert from New Jersey Bert
from New Jersey welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
about economic issues I promise I'll
call them about other things but a
couple more to get off my chest sure
um you hear a compromise a lot from the
right about Trump where they'll say like
you know I don't like him as a person
but I don't disagree with his policies
right right I think a lot of that comes
from people on the left tend to
criticize him a little too much I think
that filters out the criticism it
doesn't make its way to his policies
enough right and I'll give you an
example of one that I think you agree
with me on
um for example like the PPP loan policy
right yes we can now look back at that
and we can say that was just an abysmal
terrible policy
um you could say is the greatest form of
Socialism ever implemented we're just
shoveling money at people like crazy
well hold on a second so let's let's see
if we can break that down a little bit
Bert So when you say we were shoveling
are you talking specifically about the
business PPP aspect or are you talking
about the coveted stimulus more broadly
where money was just sent to people
good question let me clarify I'm talking
about the business side of things okay
the problem for me for the PPP program
was not that you were just giving
businesses money the problem for me was
that there wasn't enough oversight there
was tons of Fraud and it ended up being
a horrible slush fund that was my
problem with it
right but I think the policy around it
was garbage and here's why
um I don't know if you took the PPP
loans for your business or not I'm uh
technology startup and uh it was my job
to go out and administer that PPP loan
yeah so I'd find the paperwork and all
the things I was shocked at how little
there was to qualify all you had to do
is check a box that says yes my business
has been negatively affected by covid
unless you're in the business of selling
toilet paper or making coffee filters
who's who's not going to check that box
right yeah and listen I decided not to
take the money I later learned that
there were other people in my cohort who
who did take some of that money it is
true that the IRS is heavily focusing on
now auditing uh uh people who
fraudulently took money I feel fine I
mean yeah listen I get it there was
government money out there for the
taking I don't regret not taking it I
mean we everybody was home watching
shows we had a really great year that
year like it would have just been wrong
for me to take it but your point is
absolutely correct it was too easy to
get that money
and and you know Tom Brady got a million
dollar loan like why does why does
government to bail Tom Brady's company
out right that's just one example in my
circle the common uh uh talk about was
hey this is free money go out and get it
right and you need to prove you needed
it so my question is now that we can
look back at this why is it sounds like
I'm criticizing the right I'm actually
more criticized than the left like why
isn't this being talked about this is a
terrible policy that you know caused
inflation I can go and list all the
things that happen here why isn't this
being brought up well I think the left
has to criticize both Trump policy and
Trump sort of like tone and this the
non-policy stuff I think for a lot of
people the reality is Bert because of
attention spans and so many other
different factors it's much easier to
remind people about you know Trump
believed everything Putin told him and
he believed everything Kim Jong-un told
him and he drew on a marker with a he
drew with a marker uh on the hurricane
map and he wasn't sure why we couldn't
nuke Europe and a lot of that stuff is
much easier to communicate it quickly
then the policy stuff but I agree with
you completely I think the other aspect
on Trump and policy is he also didn't do
that much because so many of the things
he said he was going to do obviously
weren't going to happen so for example
the big criticism on Trump on the
israeli-palestinian conflict is he
promised to solve it within a year and
they didn't and the one thing he did
moving the air the uh Embassy to
Jerusalem was actually counterproductive
right but on a lot of these things Trump
didn't actually do anything
right right no I I absolutely the other
thing I think about too is like what if
the roles reversed here what if this was
Obama right what would the right be
saying about this this would be like Ben
gonzi Benghazi 2.0 there'll be
committees there'd be investigations why
would you let this taxpayer money go to
fraud right none of that seems to be
happening oh they'd be demanding that
Obama be put in prison if he had
overseen PPP there's no doubt about that
Bert good points and well made I
appreciate it thank you David all right
Bert from New Jersey
excellent excellent stuff